Transcriptor: Juliana Tomas
Revisor: Anna Sobota
Llevo años trabajando la comunicación
no verbal de mujeres brillantes
y hace un tiempo me di cuenta
de algo realmente curioso,
y es que cuando animaba
a una mujer a empoderarse,
aparecían instintivamente
gestos de fuerza,
pero también de cierta agresividad.
Por ejemplo, los más típicos, ¿no?
Puño en alto, lucha.
Postura de Super Woman, yo puedo con todo
o yo debo poder con todo.
Otros pasan más desapercibidos.
Mandíbula muy encajada, frustración.
O incluso, apretar los dientes
y enseñarlos , ira o ataque.
En cambio, cuando hablábamos de poderío,
reflexionábamos sobre poderío,
tanto el cuerpo como la expresión facial
se transformaban.
Adoptaban una postura
de seguridad en una misma.
Independientemente de los demás
y de cuál fuera el resultado,
una se sabía ganadora.
Por ejemplo, una mirada
desde abajo hacia arriba,
un guiño, una mirada o una sonrisa pícara,
o incluso supongo que también
por influencia flamenca,
pues algunas les daba por unas palmas
o incluso por un “zapateao”.
Y es curioso, ¿no?
Dos conceptos: poderío y empoderamiento.
Los utilizamos indistintamente,
incluso como sinónimos.
Pero la reacción corporal, la reacción
del cuerpo, es diferente.
Y quise saber por qué.
Lo que ocurre es que cuando
hablamos de empoderamiento
lo asociamos al poder social.
En cambio, cuando hablamos de poderío
llamamos al poder personal,
al poder vital.
Y hasta la fecha se nos
ha inculcado que el poder social,
es aquel que debe imponerse
sobre alguien o sobre algo.
Eso de la regla de
‘o chafo o me chafarán’.
Y ante esta concepción del poder,
muchos no nos sentimos cómodos,
ni mujeres ni hombres.
Y lo que acabamos haciendo
es entregando ese poder,
dejando ese poder en otras manos.
Y eso nos ocasiona grandes problemas,
sobre todo profesionalmente.
Perdemos oportunidades o incluso ascensos.
Supongo que muchos de vosotros habréis
oído hablar del síndrome de la impostora.
Síndrome de la impostora es esa
horrible sensación permanente de que
por muy preparada, muy formada que estés,
incluso aunque tengas
y obtengas reconocimiento social,
siempre tienes la percepción
de que no eres válida.
De que en algún momento
alguien se dará cuenta
y pondrá sobre la mesa
que no estás capacitada
para cumplir esa labor.
De hecho, el síndrome de la impostora
no es tanto el miedo
al fracaso como al éxito.
Y eso nos afecta más a las mujeres
que a los hombres.
La razón supongo que
la podemos adivinar todos.
Durante siglos a la mujer
se nos ha convencido
de que no teníamos
las suficientes capacidades,
e incluso que no teníamos derecho,
a querer alcanzar el poder y el éxito.
Para mí, el síndrome de la impostora
tiene más que ver
con el síndrome de la impostura.
Veréis, las mujeres con las que trabajo,
una de las primeras solicitudes
o peticiones que me hacen
es que por favor,
que les ayude a sonreír menos.
Sí, sí, a sonreír menos.
Que dices, ¿qué problema puede haber
en que una persona sonría?
Bueno, pues estamos en el año 21,
casi en el año 22 del siglo XXI,
y aún hay hombres que consideran
que incluso en el ámbito laboral,
si una mujer les sonríe
es porque se está insinuando.
Y muchas mujeres para ahorrarse
malentendidos y problemas,
deciden: “Bueno, pues
voy a quitarme la sonrisa”.
Hace unos años,
supongo que recordaréis muchos
de vosotros una campaña
que se inició en el metro de Nueva York,
en el que se pedía a los hombres
que, por favor, dejaran de espatarrarse
porque estaban ocupando un espacio vital
que ya no era el suyo,
sino el del usuario de al lado
e incluso a veces el de dos usuarios.
Me parece una muy buena metáfora
de lo que ocurre, o de lo que ha ocurrido,
entre hombres y mujeres.
Durante mucho tiempo el hombre ha estado
ocupando un espacio que no le pertocaba.
En comunicación no verbal, el espacio
que ocupamos es el poder que tenemos.
Normalmente se invita a las mujeres
a que hagan lo mismo que los hombres.
Es decir, que acaben ocupando
más espacio del que tienen.
Hay muchas mujeres
que no se sienten cómodas
imitando y emulando este lenguaje
corporal masculino, digamos Alfa.
Yo jamás he permitido
que una mujer dejara de sonreír.
De hecho, tampoco estoy de acuerdo
que para cambiar un sistema patriarcal
adoptemos las mismas formas y las mismas
posturas que han regido hasta la fecha.
De hecho, lo que le pido a los hombres
es que empiecen a feminizarse.
Es algo tan sencillo como
empezar a juntar las piernas.
Os aseguro que no pasa nada.
Por muy grande que la tengáis,
no va a pasar nada, os lo aseguro.
De hecho, incluso con
las sonrisas hay un montón.
Hay un registro enorme de sonrisas.
Yo siempre digo que las sinceras
se dibujan aquí, en los ojos.
No aquí, no hay que buscarlas aquí.
Y es cuando surgen
las temidas  patas de gallo
y empiezan a brillar los ojos.
Entonces ahí sí que podríamos ver alegría,
placer, incluso una cierta insinuación.
Las demás son sonrisas sociales,
sonrisas diplomáticas o,
si lo preferís, hipócritas.
Cuando en un ambiente dominado por hombres
y donde hay una minoría de mujeres
sí que hay muchas mujeres que sonríen.
Pero la que más predomina
de sonrisas es la siguiente.
Os la traduzco:
menudo capullo.
Así que ojito con interpretar los gestos,
porque a lo mejor nos estamos equivocando.
Otro de los problemas que ocasionan
el síndrome de la impostora
tiene que ver con la falta
de referentes femeninos.
Hemos estado muy faltas
De hecho, la imagen que tenemos del líder,
la imagen que tenemos del poder,
está creada por hombres y para hombres.
El liderazgo masculino
se construye con tres cualidades:
seguridad, seriedad y cercanía.
Esta imagen excluye a la mujer.
¿Por qué?
Veréis, seguridad socialmente
la asociamos con la fuerza,
con la fuerza física.
Obviamente hay excepciones,
pero en general las mujeres en este ámbito
tenemos cierta desventaja.
La seriedad.
La seriedad tiene que ver con la madurez.
Existe la figura
del madurito interesante pero,
aunque por suerte está cambiando,
una cana o una arruga
aún penaliza a la mujer.
La tercera cualidad es la proximidad,
la cercanía, el humanizarnos, empatizar.
Y ahí sí, ahí sí que tenemos
cabida las mujeres,
pero de una forma muy como accesorio.
Si baja la popularidad del líder,
ésta va a buscar a la mujer,
a la primera dama, a los niños
o incluso, ahora se ha puesto
muy de moda, a los animales.
Yo como animalista y como ellos no
lo pueden verbalizar, lo digo yo:
Por favor, dejar en paz a los animales.
Bueno, por suerte esta imagen está
cambiando y el liderazgo, también.
Estamos viviendo una transición.
De este liderazgo masculino, un tanto,
si me lo permitís, tóxico o muy tóxico,
estamos pasando a un liderazgo femenino,
un nuevo liderazgo.
La crisis sanitaria ha acelerado esta
transición y ha corroborado que funciona,
y funciona incluso mejor.
Las cualidades que han salido de la imagen
de este nuevo liderazgo son también tres:
la serenidad, la ternura y la elegancia.
La serenidad es la excelencia
de la empatía.
A un líder no le tenemos
que pedir que sea empático.
Todos los seres humanos somos empáticos,
a no ser que tengamos una discapacidad
emocional como Donald Trump.
Los demás somos empáticos.
De hecho, incluso los animales,
los mamíferos
tienen esa capacidad de ser empáticos.
Por lo tanto, lo que le debemos
exigir a un líder es que sea sereno,
que tenga esa capacidad
de gestionar las emociones,
tanto las negativas como las positivas.
Sobre todo en un momento de crisis,
en el momento en que los demás
nos podríamos bloquear.
La segunda cualidad, como
os decía, es la ternura.
Mucha gente, sobre todo las mujeres,
cuando hablo de liderazgo femenino
y cito la palabra ternura,
se echan las manos a la cabeza
y dicen: “Por Dios, qué cosa más cursi”.
Bueno, siempre pongo el mismo ejemplo:
una leona o una tigresa
son tiernas con sus crías, ¿no?
Juguetean con ellas, incluso las lamen.
Ahora, si hay un peligro, si hay
una amenaza externa, sacan las uñas.
De hecho, también para enseñar
a sus crías a protegerse,
si hay un comportamiento errático
que puede derivar en
la no supervivencia de la manada,
también corregirán esa actitud.
Yo digo que la sensibilidad
no es contraria a la firmeza.
La tercera cualidad es la elegancia.
Estéticamente, yo siempre
defino la elegancia
como ese don para hacer que algo
muy complicado resulte sencillo.
Esto llevado al campo
del liderazgo es la coherencia:
dar ejemplo, hacer que los demás
quieran mejorar, quieran ser mejores.
Hay varias personas, varios
referentes, varias líderes
que se están convirtiendo
en referentes femeninos.
Tenemos el caso de la Primera Ministra de
Nueva Zelanda, Jacinda Ardern,
la Primera Ministra de Finlandia,
Sanna Marin,
o un caso mucho más cercano, como es el de
Yolanda Díaz en el Gobierno Español.
Pero esta imagen, a diferencia del
liderazgo masculino, no excluye a nadie,
ni siquiera a los hombres.
De hecho, uno de los pioneros en poner
en práctica el liderazgo femenino
fue Barack Obama.
En resumen y en resumen gestual,
estamos pasando
o estamos haciendo este cambio,
esta transformación, esta transición
del dedito levantado de orden o amenaza
a una mano extendida
de proposición y de oferta.
Es decir, como hijos, pero también
como empleados y como gobernados,
debemos decidir si queremos
la imposición o la proposición.
Yo lo tengo claro.
Yo me quedo con el poderío.
Muchas gracias a todos.